the southern US border group says it's
moving ahead with plans to build a
private border wall in southwestern New
Mexico it's using millions of dollars
from a crowdfunding campaign to close a
border gap that the group says is very
popular with asylum seekers CBS this
morning lead national correspondent
that's David bag knows in Sunland Park
New Mexico where he spoke with the
veteran behind this controversial
project David good to see you what are
the plans his plans for this wall well
Gil they want it to be a half mile wide
by the time it's done half mile long and
they say they could complete it by this
weekend 48 hours ago the mayor showed up
and said wait a minute you're not the
right permits you need to stop your work
but now the group claims they've been
given permission by the mayor to keep
going with this video the group known as
we build the wall declared victory
saying they are now effectively
protecting a popular passage that
immigrants used to enter the US
illegally it was a highly trafficked
area the project is being spearheaded by
Brian Cole faj a triple amputee veteran
he created the GoFundMe page that has
raised more than twenty three million
dollars how much money is being spent on
this section here this is it's still
ongoing but it's gonna be around six to
eight million dollars Cole fudge is as
controversial as the wall in fact
Wednesday a Miami radio station reported
that Florida's Department of Agriculture
confirmed that the state is
investigating the fun after receiving
consumer complaints so what do you say
to the critics if we were doing anything
wrong
GoFundMe would shut this down in a
heartbeat who does manage the money
that's been deleted we have an internal
audit committee and we have an external
audit agency we can't spend any money
without getting approval the wall is
being built on privately owned land with
permission from the landowner and
backing from people like Steve Ronnie
Beck who says his son grant was murdered
by an illegal immigrant
I represent every victim of illegal
alien crime the plan has faced criticism
from city officials Tuesday the mayor of
Sunland Park New Mexico ordered the
group to stop their work construction on
the wall at this point is is out of in
violation of city ordinance the man who
owns the property wasn't available for
an interview but his representative told
us that the government has long said to
them you have a natural bear
doesn't make sense to put a wall here
George Mason University law professor
Illya Solman believes this project may
in the end generate more publicity than
impact it's unlikely they're going to
get the right to build more than a small
section of wall on privately owned Wynn
given it they can only do so if the
owners want to let them what about that
reality that you'll do it here and it
may help this land owner but in the
larger scheme of things it'll sort of be
a drop in the bucket
well we're not here to build the entire
southern border wall we're here to have
an impact with the money that we raise
to help out these communities in the
package right there you heard Brian
coalfish talk about an external audit
agency that they have he showed up this
morning right before our live shot to
say we have not yet hired that agency
but we will before the end of this tax
season they are planning a party here at
the site fireworks in all within the
next 48 hours Tony when they expect to
complete this and listen this is
controversial the critics say this group
is a bunch of white supremacists and
xenophobes but their supporters say wait
a minute that's not true they have been
more effective than the United States
government in this case all right David
thank you very much at the end of the
day does just sound like a private
landowner accepted a free wall in his
backyard yeah it's me putting up a fence
on his property